okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the Monday May 22nd meeting of the
science technology and energy committee
as usual we'll Begin by all rising and
joining representative McGee as she
leads us in the pledge
signified
States
One Nation another God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
righty Welcome to our
one of our final meetings maybe not our
our absolute final meeting for the
session but uh the session here but
certainly one of our last meetings we
have a presentation this morning by the
policy research shop at Dartmouth
College looking forward to that before
we get to that though
I'd like to talk to the committee about
a couple of other things
number one we're going to have three
bills returned from three house bills
returned from the Senate with amendments
those three bills are House Bill 233
which is a thermal wreck bill
House Bill 281 which was the repeal of
the least cost integrated resource plan
statute and House Bill 139 which
originally was a municipal group
host net metering bill
all three of those bills were amended by
the Senate and all three of those bills
I'm going to encourage that the
committee concur with the Senate
amendments
in the first of those bills HB 233
all the Senate did was change a couple
of words
uh to clarify that the department of
energy needs to approve new
methodologies for
determining determining the validity of
thermal wreck
requests
that's a simple change a logical change
I think we should just concur the other
two bills are more complicated HB 281
which was the
repeal of least cost integrated resource
planning the Senate made significant
changes to that bill they added four
other bills
three other house bills and a portion of
another house bill to that bill so it's
a mini Omnibus Bill now and it includes
the municipal group net metering host
group net metering change that was made
by hb139 removing Municipal boundaries
it also adds about eight pages of House
Bill 609 which was the reform of the
site evaluation committee House Bill 609
as you will recall
changed
the house the site evaluation committee
from being a standalone committee to
being part of the Public Utilities
Commission
well what the Senate did is they looked
at that bill and they extracted what
they thought were the most important
components of the bill without going all
the way to the
transfer of the responsibilities to the
POC
and they Incorporated those Eight Pages
of reforms of the existing site
evaluation committee into house bill
281.
in addition to that they added the text
of House Bill 251 which was a bill that
representative Thomas
filed to
require that the December electric bill
show a dollar figure for compliance for
an individual person's compliance with
the renewable portfolio standard
and
then the final piece was they added the
substance of House Bill 622 a bill we
retained
which repeals the easy board so those
are the five changes they made to HB 281
and I recommend that we concur with that
bill
and before we go on to the last bill
I'll recognize Randy Thomas for a
question thank you just want to clarify
that it was representative Douglas
Thomas that that did uh yes okay I
forgot to clarify on that
and then the final bill that was changed
by the or did you want to say something
on on 281 yes thank you Mr chair
um I'd just like to ask what is the
process for us to officially agree
whether we're going to concur or not
doing you know because we we've
certainly been discussing the um
the variety of changes that are in HP
281 in terms of you know positive
positive law versus stuff we would
prefer not see in law so what would be
the process for that
so that we're undergoing that process
right now we want to discuss it here in
committee and but ultimately the
decision rests with the with the
committee chair
okay so if if we have uh a disagreeing
opinion then
you can express it and
okay either here or on the house floor
yeah okay thanks
and let's see was there one other did I
just discuss uh no I didn't discuss HP
139 HP 139 which was the elimination of
Municipal boundaries in the
uh Municipal group host net metering
bill
was replaced in its entirety because
that text has now been added to HB 281
it was replaced in its entirety
by
the text of an amendment that
representative Summers had prepared
during our discussions of Senate bill
167. that was the hydrogen bill
which we ultimately rejected
but the Senate really
once to get a definition of green
hydrogen into statute because the Senate
believes and they have convinced me that
we need to have that definition in
statute and under in order to qualify
for federal dollars apparently there are
quite a few federal dollars that are
available
but if you don't have that
definition and statute it it hurts your
chances to qualify for some of those
federal dollars
so they replaced the text of 139 with
the text of Senate bill
167 minus any references to tax credits
or other subsidies for hydrogen
projects going forward and so I'm going
to recommend that we concur
on that bill as well
but I'm welcome to hear any discussion
on any of these bills from
the folks assembled here this morning
yes representative McGee I think when we
were discussing 281 I didn't I didn't
think I heard you say there's also the
disillusion of the easy board
which is another thing yes I I mentioned
that did you yes okay so I guess most
people here are not all that familiar
with what the easy board is or does but
we did have a meeting of the easy board
on Friday that we were both at
um where folks were both shocked and
dismayed uh at the idea of that that
work being
um
stopped I I guess I won't say stymied
because it'll be completely stopped
um so is it appropriate for us to have a
conversation about
um how we feel about that bill
yes we can talk about that but I'm going
to suggest that we wait until after our
presentation because I don't want to
hold these folks from Dartmouth up too
much longer but if you want to have a
conversation about that we can do that
terrific thank you
so now let's uh turn our attention to a
presentation
that
the
policy research shop at Dartmouth asked
me if I wanted them to do any research
for us back in the fall and I said yes
you could look into the question of
whether biomass electricity can be
generated in New Hampshire
or New England without subsidies and so
they have done that and they have a
presentation here for us this morning so
I'd like to turn the floor over to
mayhack batra and Beatrice capio
so that they can tell us what they've
discovered and welcome to you both
appreciate you coming down making the
Trek from Hanover down here this morning
thankfully the weather was good I hope
you had a pleasant ride and uh
we'll uh probably ask you some questions
as you go along but we'll look forward
to hearing your presentation so take it
away thank you
chairman Vose members of the committee
I'm pleased to join you today and
Concord alongside my colleague Beatrice
capio my name is mahak batra and the two
of us are researchers at the policy
class of 1964 policy research shop from
the Nelson a Rockefeller Center at
Dartmouth College
the policy research shop produces
non-partisan policy analyzes and we
present our findings today in a
non-advocacy manner
today we'll be presenting on biomass
electricity generation and capacity in
New Hampshire which is the subject of a
recent report that has been circulated
to the committee by the center and my
colleagues we are here to present the
facts on this important issue today
we will begin with an overview of
biomass before discussing our research
design and findings we'll look forward
to your questions barring any immediate
needs at the end of the presentation we
have prepared
to start off biomass refers to any plant
or plant-derived material that can be
converted into energy this includes not
only wood but also agricultural residues
Municipal solid waste and gas extracted
from landfills these products can be
burned in to produce heat that powers
electric generators are processed into
biofuels for transportation applications
today we will be focusing on Wood
related biomass electricity generation
due to the extensive forests and solid
tonnage of wood-related biomass
resources as depicted here in New
Hampshire
it is worth noting that while widely
considered a renewable energy source the
sustainability of biomass and practice
is somewhat debated
drawing on the context of where we're
coming from from the Upper Valley
Professor Andrew Friedland from
Dartmouth authored a recent opinion
column in the Valley news about the
hidden costs of Wood-Fired and wood
biomass not too long after Professor Ben
Steele of Colby Sawyer College responded
noting that plants have found ways to
manage emissions and arguing that
biomass is an important element of an
electrical generation mix our report in
part seeks to situate the viability of
biomass among other renewable options
lastly biomass has historically not been
price competitive with other electricity
sources motivating the generation of our
report and research question
our subsidies required for biomass
electricity generation in New Hampshire
which asks whether subsidies are
required for biomass electricity
generation New Hampshire in constructing
this report the research team spoke with
a range of experts
the team spoke with professors mark
laser and Andrew Friedland from
Dartmouth
we've consulted individuals from the
McNeil power plant and Vermont and
Bridgewater power plant in New Hampshire
and we also spoke with individuals from
stakeholder groups in the logging
industry natural resources Consulting
and from the neighboring state
governments
the report takes a two-pronged approach
to considering this problem first the
report Compares biomass to other sources
of renewable and non-renewable energy
especially Natural Gas
second the report draws on findings from
case studies in neighboring Maine and
Vermont to considering how to consider
how New Hampshire is faring relatively
speaking on biomass generation and
broader renewable energy commitments
in the report we compare biomass among
other electricity sources when it comes
to the construction and maintenance for
biomass related infrastructure
we conclude
sorry first excuse me to understand it
fully if biomass is economically viable
we first compare biomass to other energy
sources it's first important to compare
the fuel costs of other sources both
non-renewable and renewable to determine
how they compare to biomass in the field
of energy production fuel costs are
often the greatest expense for power
plants and the fluctuations in price of
feedstock can significantly influence
the cost of electricity being produced
in New Hampshire the average price of
wood of for biomass electricity
generation is 1850 to 32 per ton Drive
wood is produced by stacking freshly cut
lumber for a few years before burning it
in order to decrease its moisture
content
usually one ton of wood
is expect to generate one megawatt of
electricity
natural gas in New Hampshire usually
costs
7.64 cents per thousand cubic feet
producing one megawatt of electricity
requires a combustion of seven thousand
six hundred thousand cubic feet
producing one megawatt of electricity
requires the combustion of 7 600 cubic
feet of natural gas the data in table
two from the eia
right here shows that the biomass
electricity has slightly lower fuel
costs than natural gas it takes like I
said before
18.50 to 32 dollars of wood to produce
one megawatt of electricity whereas for
natural gas it's required to produce the
same megawatt hour which would cost
around 58 dollars
okay
we also demonstrate that wood chip
prices as seen here are highly variable
year to year and do not reflect the full
story of the biomass generation cost
thus relative comparisons with other
energy sources are more useful from an
economic analysis standpoint than purely
centering wood or the fuel for this
formula of electricity cost
as you can see in this table
in the report we also compare biomass
among other electricity sources when it
comes to the construction and
maintenance required for biomass related
infrastructure we conclude that biomass
construction and maintenance costs are
significantly higher compared to other
sources of electricity when considering
their relative output further we
considered how the price of electricity
has changed per megawatt over time we
see that the market price rarely reaches
or exceeds the subsidy price considered
and set under sp365 which was a previous
subsidy put in place in New Hampshire
thus prior to New Hampshire subsidy
levels did not adequately or thoroughly
affect the biomass generation market and
broader energy generation landscape in
the state
furthermore
National advised Financial advisory and
asset management firm Lazard assessed
the nationalized levelized cost of
energy for renewable and conventional
energy sources without subsidies and
found that the only specific forms of
renewable energy I.E solar and wind
resources are cost competitive with
fossil fuels this was a figure from the
report and was also included in the New
Hampshire's 10-year energy strategy
report released in 2022 and that same
analysis there was discussion about how
traditionally subsidized renewable
sources like biomass cannot maintain
competitiveness in Regional electricity
markets without State intervention the
report mentions that several biomass
facilities have recently shut down or
suspended their operations
ISO New England New England's non-profit
Regional transmission organization only
projects Eight megawatts coming from
biomass facilities based on the iso New
England generator the interconnection
queue in February 2021
entering our case studies portion of the
report we first turned to our neighbors
in Vermont
the report highlights the McNeil
Generating Station the plant's net
operating costs including transportation
for the past two fiscal years have
ranged between 91 and 101
dollars per megawatt hour a
representative from the plant talked
about their positive relationship with
State leadership and the necessity of
subsidies at the federal and state
levels to support fair pricing like
through a tax credit program
next we look at Maine
Lisa Smith from the governor's Energy
Office described that the cost of
operating means biomass generation
plants exceeded revenues per year by
around one to two million dollars in the
past couple years
talking with Eric Kingsley from
Innovative resource Solutions we further
learned that biomass plants are required
to sell their electricity at around 5
cents per kilowatt hour and that plants
must buy their fuel at less than ten
dollars and eight cents per ton in order
to break even
thus Kingsley and Smith underlined the
need for policy intervention in order to
support the viability of biomass as a
renewable source of electricity in Maine
and describe the need for a related
course of action in New Hampshire
moreover all three of these states share
a similar climate High Forest cover
population density and energy demand
but what separates them is the renewable
energy standards and state assistance
that they offer energy providers all
three states also have unique class
distinctions for the renewable energy
standards to start off New Hampshire's
renewable portfolio standard has a
requirement for its electricity
providers to obtain renewable energy
credits or certificates Recs equivalent
to 25.2 percent of retail electricity
sold to end customers by 2025. of that
total eight percent falls under the
class 3 distinction
the total class 1 RPS obligation will be
15 by 2025 which is new renewable energy
sources following the establishment of
renewable portfolio standard New
Hampshire's SB 51 enacted in June 2017
establish a committee to study subsidies
for energy projects the studies of this
bill are referenced throughout the paper
such as the study on the economic
viability of renewable portfolio
standard class 3 biomass electric
generation resources in New Hampshire
and found that high and consistent
subsidies for the biomass industry would
be needed to work with New Hampshire's
portfolio standard this low renewable
portfolio energy standard has deterred
the biomass industry from taking off
on the other hand Vermont's renewable
energy standard does not have any
distinctions for when a facility began
operations even though the state has
much higher standard requiring 55
percent of its energy to come from
renewable sources in 2017 their system
allows for flexibility in the Vermont's
RPS similarly Maine has high standards
it requires eighty percent of its
electricity to be supplied by renewable
sources by 2030. Maine requires that 30
of its load must be satisfied by
renewable electricity generating
generation in 2019 under Class 2 and 10
percent must be satisfied by a new
renewable sources under class one and an
increasing number of amounts of
renewable energy under class 1a and
thermal renewable energy credits thus
both states have higher standards for
renewable energy production
because both Vermont and Maine require
such a high portion of their energy
portfolio come from renewable sources
and biomasses in excess because of high
Force cover in their respective States
they facilitate a process for biomass
with State assistance these
considerations could potentially point
to why New Hampshire struggles with
supporting biomass production and will
continue to do so
in summary through this research we
first first spoke with experts and
stakeholders developed two case studies
and reached out to biomass facilities
then we considered the economic
feasibility of biomass electricity in
New Hampshire and the state's current
renewable energy standards and lastly as
my colleague just noted we could have
concluded that subsidies and policy
intervention are necessary for biomass
to thrive in New Hampshire
as New Hampshire is committed to a
renewable portfolio standard the state
may need to seek investment in
alternative energy sources in order to
generate electricity more cleanly and
sustainably
with the state's vast Forest resources
what represents a possible alternative
to traditional fossil fuels however
adopting any new fuel source like wood
in the state's energy portfolio
generates questions of viability and
cost
next steps for this committee and
broader research on renewable energy in
New Hampshire could involve the study of
the specific subsidy level required for
biomasses viability in New Hampshire and
the renewable energy standards in the
state as well as consideration of the
relative viability of other non-biomass
related renewable energy forms
thank you for your attention and time we
look forward to your questions on the
research
and thank you for a excellent
presentation we appreciated that
and I'm sure the committee has some
questions for you so who wants to go
first anybody
representative Bernardi will go first
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you folks
so
you've indicated that a subsidy is
necessary what are we looking at T-Rex
and what level of uh subsidy is
uh I guess expected to be necessary to
ensure biomass survives or thrives
obviously this was like out of our scope
of research to look at what level of
subsidy
um we looked at but
um if you look at this
graph right here for SB 365 the subsidy
the market repair price never really
went above 50 except for the polar
vortex of 2014 so we would expect if you
were to do further research it would
be around that 50 amount but of course
that would
be a point of further research for you
guys
thank you
additional questions
representative lewicki uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you
um
one of the things I keep wondering about
I actually visited the Bridgewater plant
and
um the issue that I am concerned with is
latent heat of vaporization of water
basically if you send water up the
chimney it's going to cost you're not
going to be producing energy efficiently
and if
um even with dry wood
there's going to be some of that and so
have you thought about that at all
I'll say that that was not this you know
primary subject of this report
um but certainly you know further
research could consider the efficiency
of individual plants themselves and how
for example they differ with regard uh
to you know using dry wood and wetwood
as you're describing
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um with regard to the case study in
Vermont you said that it receives
federal and state subsidies did you
break that down into uh percentage of
each subsidy
uh we did not
[Music]
federal and state subsidies what we can
say is that
um yeah they didn't
so the when we talked to the McNeil
generating plant they did not receive
any direct subsidies what they did
receive is a 5.16 million dollar Grant
um in conjunction with um several local
organizations this grant has just I
think gone into effect this past year
and that you can look into several news
sources have talked about it and we can
provide more information for you guys
about this but um that is what they're
working on right now it's a huge Federal
grant has just gone into effect and it
was coordinated by Representative
Patrick Leahy
thank you yeah and I would just add to
that briefly on page nine of the report
if you have it in front of you
um I believe it's been circulated to
this committee uh we also at the McNiel
plant they described the federal
renewable electricity production tax
credit for example so there are various
tax credit programs that this committee
may want to look into on that point let
me clarify real quickly the report has
not been sent to all members of the
committee yet
I plan to do that later today I did not
want to send them send it to them prior
to your presentation because I didn't
want to steal any of your thunder
but the full report will be made
available to the committee shortly
wonderful well we hope
we hope out not just from this
presentation but also from the full
report it also I believe is available on
um the Rockefeller Center's website
under policy research briefs sure
representative floje uh thank you Jimmy
uh along with the report
if you could uh ask if the
testimony presented could be included
with what we have here in hard copy
okay
could you provide your written testimony
um to the committee as well
speaker notes
yeah yeah there are more Yes you heard
your notes
sure yeah
representative
follow-up I think electronically will be
enough to save paper and all
for you know we don't need all the
printouts just to come yes hard copy not
required just email will be fine we're
more than happy to do so
um also refer the committee to the
references section of the report itself
which I understand will be made
available soon it references for example
um you know as we've noted in the
presentation the various stakeholders
that were interviewed so if you're
interested in perhaps corresponding with
them directly that would also be a good
point of contact
okay I have a question for you you
briefly mentioned in your presentation
that there were a couple of op-eds
written by
Dartmouth professors about this question
did you read those and could you Briefly
summarize those to us
so um Prof
ESS Friedland we first talked to him and
then he talked in the Valley News and he
was one of the first people
um
who
discussed how biomass generation is not
a viable source of
um
like um
electricity generation in New Hampshire
um that was like the basic premise of
his argument and from there we went off
and did our research and the
next
thing we mentioned was from Ben Steele
who's from a Kobe Sawyer College he's
actually not a Dartmouth professor and
he responded to Professor Friedland and
basically said to the opposite and that
was kind of what sparked our research in
this debate whether it's biomass
sustainable is biomass economically
viable it kind of like spurred what
we're kind of looking at as our Crux of
the argument these two points is that
first economically viable and two is it
economically competitive it's like both
of those things
and both of those sources are mentioned
in your references in the report
and they're both also on the Valley News
great okay I'd refer the committee
specifically to page one of the report
that will be circulated for my
understanding shortly uh which
references both professors and their
their columns from Dartmouth and Colby
Sawyer respectively
right
representative McGee has a question
thank you and thank you for being here
today this is a well done report I
appreciate the limited scope I think
it's very helpful
um for you know levelized data and all
that it's very it's very well done
um my question is around for follow-up
you were talking about there are many
different aspects you could follow
but um on the page with the uh
it wasn't this one yeah was the
comparing fuel costs
I think we're always very concerned with
that
um that aspect of cost but when we had
hearings on biomass in New Hampshire
several years ago
we heard from industries that relied on
or were compatible with the biomass
plants that existed at the time and
there was conversation around sort of
the cost benefit analysis of having
economic stimulus in the energy sector
that was in State versus sending dollars
out of state
so I wonder if in terms of the economics
any of the externalities Beyond RPS
compliance or you know other
policy pieces that are put in place were
considered in terms of the
cost analysis
sure we can describe a couple you're
from Dartmouth so we want to put you
through the ringer yeah thank you we can
describe a couple
um you know other components that went
into kind of the economic viability
angle of this one of them was about job
creation and that's referenced
throughout the report with regard to
kind of the existing jobs in biomass in
the state of New Hampshire the other
research that we did also looked a
little bit at what those kind of
I don't want to say necessarily failing
but at least
um biomass plants that fall kind of down
the less efficient end of the Spectrum
in New Hampshire and those I will say
kind of to your point about keeping
resources in state I believe a main
company actually has at least been in
kind of
exercises to acquire those plants so I'd
say that that is another angle that we
looked at so both the jobs angle in the
state of New Hampshire as well as as I
was just referencing ultimately where
you know these plants are and who owns
and operates them which appears to be
trending out of state
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman uh so uh
representative lewicki brought up the
the concept of ensuring that we have dry
wood
it
maximizes the efficiency of these of
these plants when you looked and
discussed at the different plants did
you identify Optimum ways of drying is
it
covered material materials uh out in the
sun chipped uh what what activity
maximizes that that benefit
sure I would say that we didn't
necessarily look directly into you know
how to optimize the wood drawing process
what I will say is that as our previous
slides have shown just generally the
wood chip Market tends to be quite
variable year to year so that can make
it a little bit difficult to decipher
between years and the relative
efficiency at drying wood
additionally we looked a little bit at
you know the plants themselves and
compared them especially among this like
class one class two class three
spectrum and so hopefully that can
provide a little bit of an angle but we
didn't necessarily look at this idea of
optimal wood drawing I suppose
thank you
representative Nutter has a question
not her
that's what I said okay I didn't hear it
I was just thinking back a couple of
terms ago I think we we had um all day
hearing and we had different people
representing businesses that benefit
from biomass like uh one was talking
about how clearing the forests helps
prevent forest fires uh there was a
woman who her business was to collect
the Ash and they used it as fertilizer
and I wondered if these other businesses
were taken into consideration when you
researched your report and the cost
benefit ratio
so we reached out to as many
organizations as possible we reached out
to like
um the logging industry like different
types of stakeholders most of them did
not respond we also reached out to the
New Hampshire Department of energy to
ask for more stakeholders so
and they gave us some names
um most of them were not able to get
back to us in time for this report to be
released but we did try to get um the
most type of reach we could to answer
the question as best we could
I'd also just add to that briefly
obviously you know there's a
equilibrium amount of forest cover that
is appropriate in the state so with
regard to you know the use of those
resources we need to make sure that
whatever solution is implemented or way
that biomass and other forms of
electricity that rely on for example
wood resources that whatever that is
ultimately ends up being renewable
um that whatever you know Solutions you
all are debating and end up considering
that they ultimately meet that kind of
renewable idea where we're not you know
using too much of something that we
can't get again forests are resilient
but we need to ensure that we're not
necessarily relying on them in such a
way that we're not diversifying the
electrical generation mix and I would
also note just as a general point that
the type of wood that's used in Wood
biomass generation is not you know
pristine Lumber it tends to be
various kinds of you know I mean we're
talking about wood chips but lower grade
wood uh and I would say that the report
itself which will be circulated soon
does a pretty good job of explaining the
types of wood that are used and kind of
how they fit in especially with the
lumber industry here
representative Noel has a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
questions uh for a very good
presentation
um I was wondering if if you've given
any consideration to alternative uses
for the biomass fuel
uh were there other considerations given
there and is this the best use that can
be made of that fuel
[Music]
a great question I would say that with
regard to the actual fuel used to
generate
biomass energy and relatedly electricity
uh certainly you know the timber for
example that is used the wood chips that
are used from our understanding are not
particularly useful in other contexts
given that they're of this lower grade
lower quality
I will also say that I think the report
considers for example you know where
exactly this wood is coming from and
concludes that for example we probably
could not be using the wood to put
together these wonderful desks in this
room today and thus our probably pretty
useful
in biomass generation and the kind of
current context I'll also say that
biomass generally as the report goes
into in more depth can be used for more
than just electricity a lot of it
happens to be used for for example
industrial heating even just Heating in
people's homes Transportation they're
more you know uses for biomass energy
itself than just you know creating the
current that we use to charge our
computers for example
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you both for
being here and I just want to follow up
on representative Noel's question so I'm
imagining a world where we just don't
even have the capability to use biomass
to generate electricity or heat
there are these trees some of them are
useful some are not the ones that are
not that are harvested what could happen
to them then well what would would the
chips just pile up somewhere and and rot
and maybe Catch Fire I mean what any
ideas what the alternatives are
to using this wood for biomass
um I will direct you when you have the
report in front of you to page two which
goes into again what I've been
describing as low grade wood as well as
what is described as waste wood and I
would say that
I'm sorry but I am not entirely sure
about you know the proportion of low
grade wood to waste what that goes into
the biomass fuel pool but certainly
waste wood things like uh you know wood
that comes out of processing facilities
or you know that is procured from
Sawmills as we go into briefly uh
probably would not be particularly
useful in other contexts but I will say
that further research can consider that
question more in depth
representative partial has a question
Sharon thank you for your presentation
what not a lot of that would dust remain
uh in the wood lots and not be harvested
to begin with if there was not a use for
it
do a follow-up on time form of episode
she's going to make sure I understand
the question would the wood not be out
there would that so we're using for to
fuel these biomass plants if there was
no market for it uh the law the
Foresters would not be going to harvest
it to begin with is what I understand
perhaps good question uh again the
report didn't directly look into you
know where this waste would or low-grade
wood could go beyond biomass generation
I'll be clear on that I will say that I
think that the report makes clear though
for example
um some options for for example
um more efficient plants that may use
the wood in a slightly different way
follow-up
I guess a follow-up to that question
would be is that
um
a side benefit from to biomass would be
ensuring that there is a market for the
waste wood so that we do have force that
are well managed that helps to pay for
the world management of our forests yeah
like a way you can look at biome the
Maya Mass industry is that like there's
this wood that is undesirable
as in like low-grade wood and the
biomass industry is basically a
byproduct of it
one of the sorry could I
present one of the other benefits that
we read about within the context of
biomass energy generation in New
Hampshire specifically is also that New
Hampshire's kind of logging industry is
relatively traditional compared to
what's going on in other states meaning
that a lot of it is you know
the timber that you see on the highways
and hope it doesn't fall through your
windshield when you're driving to work
or school every day and so one of the
benefits of biomass or I will just say
broader more alternative you know forms
of use for this wood is that it would
kind of revitalize for example the
logging industry and to your point we're
not 100 sure based on this report you
know where that would may go elsewhere
but one of the perks of biomass
electricity generation is that it kind
of steers at least part of the existing
industry in the state away from more
traditional forms
of production that makes sense and it
also just helps generally with Forest
management I did read an article where
it said that like forest fires and um
other like bushfires and things like
that are managed because of this bipart
product of the biomass industry
there is a legislatively established
commission that is looking into this
question of alternative uses for biomass
it's been in operation for
at least a year and I'm not sure when
its first report is due but they have
been making progress in in coming up
with some alternative uses for for
biomass representative McGee has a
question thank you thanks for taking my
question again this is kind of a
two-parter when we were having those
hearings I heard from a constituent who
owned a large tract of land
and his concern was that the value of
the land that many of the people who own
the forest in the state
would be devalued by the fact that the
low-grade Timber no longer had value
which was helping him pay his taxes and
that kind of thing so I just thought
that was an interesting angle because
it could very much mean that some people
will not be able to hold on to their
properties and they will be sold to the
highest bidder outside the state so the
change in the whole traditional
ecosystem
around uh around the harvesting of the
low-grade Timber I think is a question
that for for thinking about because it
is back to economics right the what is
how is it viable how are we using it is
it being used locally and is there even
an economics to getting it from point A
to point B so that when it gets to that
factory and they have to pay for that
transport and that logging does it all
get rolled into the price at a feasible
price right so that's um the first one I
wanted to make but the second thing is
you were talking also about how there
were better and worse run plants and I
know we heard testimony from our
department of environmental services
that they
um were
allowing plants to be considered
renewable in terms of wrecks or tracks
based upon what they had been doing to
make sure that any emissions coming from
the plant have been cleaned up to a
certain degree So when you say better or
worse or whatever
labels you used can you describe for us
if there is any difference as far as you
know in terms of how renewable plants
are these days because my understanding
is the technology has improved but I
really don't know a lot about it
yeah I think the first distinction that
you can make and the distinctions will
be made clear in the report is between
first class 1 and class three biomass
plants class one biomass sorry class one
biomass plants are new renewable energy
plants they started operation after like
January 2006 and they first have higher
efficiency rates than class 3 biomass
plants and are going to be your most
renewable and clean biomass plants class
3 biomass plants which they're not many
of left anymore
are going to be less efficient
and are going to be the ones that are a
little bit poorer in terms of outputting
and of having this renewable aspect to
them they also are the ones I guess
we're trying to focus on today in terms
of looking at like costs and looking at
but whether they're like need subsidies
because they are the ones unfortunately
struggling
and I'm sure that the previous testimony
noted and explicated a little bit more
in depth than we have today exactly what
efficiency means um with regard to
electricity generation in broader energy
generation but when we look at biomass
power right now it's estimated that the
efficiency of plants is about 25 to 30
percent and this compares to you for
example
nuclear energy power which is roughly 50
percent of New Hampshire's electricity
as I'm sure you all are aware and is
about 34 to 36 percent efficient I'm
reading from page two and you all have
the report in front of you and the newer
nuclear plants for example can be up to
39 efficient so hopefully that gives you
a sense of kind of the trajectory
generally
um among different forms of electricity
with regard to their efficiency and how
that is progressing as newer technology
is available I will also note that one
of the difficulties that we talk about
the this distinction between Class 1 and
class 3 plants is that it's not
particularly straightforward as you may
imagine to create a new plant or in some
ways I don't believe it's right now
possible to convert a plant from like a
class three plant to a class one plant
and as our previous slide showed
um for example on the left we see the
average construction cost of uh
different plants for different forms of
energy generation and we see that
essentially the payoff for a biomass
uh isn't particularly comparable to
what's going on with other forms
electricity essentially underlining that
biomass plants are really expensive to
make and their actual efficiency even
when they are good and we're investing a
lot in them you know it's still pretty
high for what we get out
representative lewicki has another
question uh thank you Mr chairman I'm
not sure whether it's a question a
comment or what but I think in terms of
looking at efficiency
the whole system efficiency would seem
to have to be included a nuclear plant
has very few Transportation costs but if
you start adding in transportation costs
and so forth for biomass call whatever
um it would seem that that would be a
substantial variable
yes we've tried to minimize uh kind of
the math you will have to do in reading
the report with regard to what for
example those Transportation costs
you're describing especially with regard
to a comparison to nuclear power
um for example with regard to the
Vermont numbers if we look at the McNeil
plant these net operating costs for
example we're discussing are inclusive
of transportation for example so
hopefully that can better help the
committee and you for example in
determining exactly you know more
fairer comparison among other sources
but certainly a concern but I do want to
note for nuclear which is also included
in your 10-year strategy report that was
released I think this past year is that
um it does have this zero carbon aspect
to it which makes it a little and it is
a little bit more cost competitive
compared to biomass which makes it I
think a more viable source of energy at
this point
representative Noel
thank you Mr chairman
the hard question that we as a committee
have to answer is does the State of New
Hampshire want to continue subsidizing
biomass have you looked into this enough
to form an opinion on that
sure well reiterate to the committee
that we're hearing a non-advocacy manner
so we're just describing
um you know how New Hampshire is faring
relative to you know our neighbors in
Maine and Vermont and I would say that
two things two kind of possible Paths of
action were determined in creating this
report one is that there could be some
version of a more direct I'm not going
to say direct because that has
connotations but a more direct form of
subsidization for the plants themselves
in the state of New Hampshire and the
other as my colleague kind of alluded to
toward the end is that the actual
renewable energy standards could be
shifted in a way that would change the
electrical generation mix and
potentially support you know further
subsidies for biomass plants so they're
not here today to necessarily provide
you with a subsidy level that makes
sense I know we described a little bit
uh you know within the context of the
subsidy Level under SB 365 5 which of
course
is rather contentious for my
understanding here but hopefully our the
report gives a sense of you know future
Paths of action either directly or
indirectly out of this committee and out
of this house and government and you
know can help at least provide a little
bit of a bigger picture about what's
going on elsewhere
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you again
so going back to what we were just
talking about the construction cost
I'm struck by the the cost for biomass
being twice as much as anything else
except solar where it's almost twice as
much and you know I think about solar
which of course uses a lot of land
what accounts for the very high
construction cost of a biomass plant
that is an excellent question and I will
say that the report again did not look
directly into the mechanics of
individual biomass plants
um but certainly we can see that the you
know cost comparison
um demonstrates that biomass is pretty
expensive when it comes to creating a
new plant the reason I will say that
explains part of you know frankly not
spending all too much time researching
on that question is that we're looking
specifically at the existing biomass
plants and not necessarily the
construction of new ones in this context
but certainly if the state is in the
long term interest in investing in the
construction of new plants cost would be
a bigger issue there
also um heating infrastructure makes the
cost of the plant become really high
yeah the actual process of like
producing electricity based on like from
biomass is pretty technical we've got to
have the boiler we've got to be burning
something and you know of course making
that boiler work which spins the term
line which goes to generator like it's
it's quite involved compared to some of
these other sources for example if we
just think of you know what a wind
turbine looks like for example the
infrastructure just looks pretty
different
does that answer your question
okay I have a question for you the
levelized cost of energy slide
could you tell us where you got your
levelized cost of energy for each of
these categories and did it include
the cost to backup intermittent
generation
so I don't believe it included the cost
to backup intermittent generation first
off and this is a national number so
these are not New Hampshire specific
this is from the wealth management and
National Financial advisory firm Lazard
and this is the same graph that was
included in your 10-year New Hampshire
energy strategy report released last
year and it's just to show that wind and
solar is the only unsubsidized or the
only cost competitive
um
renewable energy sources that are
competitive with conventional sources
such as
um
natural gas and in some cases coal so
that is what I wanted to show I
understand that the figure is a little
bit complicated but at the Baseline that
is all I wanted to show with this figure
and to underline again this is an up
subsidized analysis to begin with so
hopefully that gives the committee a
pretty good sense of kind of where are
these sources of um energy fair in
comparison to one another without
subsidies or anything like that
um and further I'll just note on the
intermittent for example note that you
were describing
um one of the things we were looking at
is for example with regard to Coal we
know that coal can be used in state of
New Hampshire if it's particularly high
demand season for example and just to
kind of underline this point that this
is a national analysis not everywhere is
going to have the kind of polar vortexes
that we see here that cause for example
that big spike if we go back to the
subsidy graph here so it depends across
the country where you're looking at
every state also has different resources
different infrastructure for example but
that we see nationally generally
speaking in that levelized analysis how
different forms of energy compare
representative floje uh thank you chair
thank you for your research and your
presentation
um
I do understand page three you're
focused on one item of
is there subsidies uh economical for
wood of bio
in your research
as we found out in research have you
found any other lines you did not go on
because that was not part of your charge
such as all many of the other
generators have subsidies also
we didn't look into canases survive
did you notice where we could have gone
with a research
a tangent if I could say of the rate of
return to New Hampshire's rate payers
and taxpayers
on subsidies you know like you heard
mentioned uh
the logging industry the tourists
upgrading our Force
is there another report out there thank
you
um yeah there are a lot of different
directions we could have gone with our
research in terms of rate of return for
rate pairs
um there was a report that we did
reference a lot in our research and did
look at a lot in her research and that
was a report released in 2018 by New
Hampshire itself it's the report on
economic viability of class 3 biomass
facilities
um and that found that the rate of
return
um the cost of
um for rate pairs for um subsidies was 3
million from 2014 to 2017 for this SB
365 and other subsidies
um and of course there was a lot of
different analysis that that report did
it's a 52-page report
um I think that would be a really
insightful report to look at if you guys
were to do further research on doing
another subsidy and which level of
subsidy you would like to do on class
three in class one biomass abilities in
the future but um in terms of doing
further research there were a lot of
different directions we could go of
course we were limited in scope and the
people who responded to us but um yeah
we also know that there's a great deal
of research as you all have alluded to
um with regard to study on this issue in
the state
um both from you know for example you
know policy researchers like ourselves
but also within the state
um my colleague referenced for example
this report from 2018 and December from
the New Hampshire office of strategic
initiatives so it's a study on the
economic viability of specifically those
class III plants which is referenced
throughout the report and I would
recommend and hopefully this
presentation and report that we have put
together can Inspire as my colleague
alluded to some further research both
you know externally and also within for
example offices the office of strategic
initiatives and other entities within
the state
yes having read that 2018 report by
Matthew Mayu I can highly recommend it
excellent report
any further questions from the committee
well seeing none I want to thank you
both for a wonderful presentation and a
very informative report which the
committee will have in its hands shortly
and if we have questions could we ask
you via email for additional information
you're more than welcome to contact
um you know the names listed on the
report as well as our own names listed
on the slides today and I am sure the
center could get you it get you all in
touch with us directly as well and I
also reference the policy research Shop
website for general information about
these types of analyzes and also again
the brief if you're interested in seeing
it before it becomes available over
email later today
wonderful and I'd also like to thank
thank Michael Wales for setting uh
who I guess you're the director of the
policy research shop is that correct
faculty Mentor okay well whatever your
role we appreciate you performing it and
helping us out with arranging for this
report and for
coming here this morning to present it
to us we thank you all of you
you guys so much thank you
so before we wrap up our activity this
morning I know representative McGee you
wanted to discuss a little bit about the
amendments to Senate to House Bill 281
this is specifically research the
amendment regarding the repeal of the
easy board
yes I I think uh the points that I
wanted to make are it sometimes it's
referred to as a Christmas tree bill
right a number of different bills get
attached or an Omnibus or
quasi Omnibus or a half Omnibus
um and what ends up happening is there
are bills that you would like to see
advance in bills that you really would
oppose and I think that's the case
um for myself on 281
um I think there's been a lot of
discussion around how the least cost
integrated resource planning
process needed revamping for current
circumstances but as I mentioned in the
hearing on this bill in the Senate
um we just passed Senate Bill 54
allowing the utilities to enter into
long-term purchase power agreements and
that creates a situation that's very
similar to the reason that the least
cost integrated resource planning was
put in place in the first place to to
protect people from long-term stranded
costs for Capital Investments or
Investments that are larger being
entered into by the utilities so I see
it being
um
uh
not wise for us to say let's eliminate
least cost integrated resource planning
before we've decided what it is that
should replace it especially at a time
when we're allowing large-term contracts
to go forward which could ultimately put
the rate payer
on the hook
so I so that's
and I personally
feel as though the easy board is in the
midst of doing a bunch of really useful
work which was illustrated by the
wonderful presentation we had on Friday
from one of our members and so
um that too is something I disagree with
and finally I'll just say I I don't
think including
um HB 251's language is is useful in any
way no one was asking for it it will
confuse people in my opinion and it's
also something that the rate payers will
have to pay for in terms of a change on
the utility bill
and that change is not based on the
user's actual charges but rather an
aggregate mean of charges on an
estimated Bill and so I think it just
confuses the issue further of what's
being
charged to people in terms of renewable
portfolio standards and so I am pretty
much opposed to that bill as well so
that's three out of five things on there
that I
I don't think I could vote for
and that's as quick as I could say it
so would it be your opinion then that we
should none concur with the Senate
amendment that would be my
recommendation I know it's not popular
with you know the folks that are that
are sending it to us from the Senate but
that would that would be my
recommendation
any further discussion on this issue
representative Corman
thank you
um and there's also the the issue of the
site evaluation committee and I I did
notice that what the amendment from the
Senate does is it seems to streamline
parts of the process that's a good thing
but of course we did retain
hb609 in committee
and it seems to me that if we're really
thinking about what we want to do about
the site evaluation committee we should
be looking at it
all together rather than piece by piece
so I I would rather us really look at
what to do with 609 and think about how
we should be revamping
not just the processes but possibly the
membership as as the bill originally uh
submitted did rather than just doing a
piecemeal
well since we retain that bill we can
still do that
even if House Bill 281 passes
and make some adjustments and changes to
the existing site evaluation committee
we can still use House Bill 609 to make
additional changes
if we deem them to be worthy of of
making so
it doesn't preclude further work on
reforms to the site evaluation committee
and and I understand that I'm just
thinking it's best to look at the whole
thing at once together rather than piece
by piece but but I do agree that the
changes that the Senate has recommended
will at least streamline the process
further discussion
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman
um well as the sponsor of the
Bill to repeal easy board I'm totally in
favor of the uh of that portion of of
I would only comment on the December
electric bill uh okay
Adder that uh will explain RPS costs uh
when we went through that bill it was
made clear that there would be no
additional costs to Consumers to include
that
um so I'm again in in favor of that uh
the improvements to the site evaluation
uh commission
um I uh I I favor those uh improvements
I also agree that maybe we can take a
broader and
larger examination of the in the
entirety of the process but uh if we
don't get there
we've at least moved forward on that on
that front
um
the only thing that concerns me at all
in in the bill is is what they've done
with the municipal boundaries and what
that means for uh uh potential
um
shifting of costs to uh to rate payers
so in aggregate I would I would be in
favor of moving forward with 281.
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
yeah I'd like to thank my colleague
representative Bernardi for bringing up
the fact that in the hearing we were
told there would be no costs for adding
that information on the December bill
but the bill language in fact says that
costs incurred will be
allowed to be charged back to the rate
payer so the bill language actually says
that they will be charged for those
changes because
I don't know when that was included but
it was my understanding as well in the
hearing that it would not cost anything
but the language of the bill does not
state that it states that the costs will
be charged to the ratepayer
that is protective language it's fairly
standard language
in bills yes it is there you're right
any further discussion
sorry there is such a
limited attendance here this morning we
couldn't have a
a full and robust discussion of this
issue but
people have lives and other things they
have to do and jobs yeah so
all right
well that wraps up and concludes then
our activity for this morning I want to
thank everybody for being here and I
guess we won't see you again in
committee until sometime in June
representative Thomas who also isn't
here because I believe he's he's in the
building but I believe he's with the
Londonderry fourth graders
and um
he's try still trying to set up a a trip
up to the Burgess bio
um Power Plant and possibly the Q
hydrogen plant up in the north country
I don't know how that's going he's not
here to report on it but
that probably will be the next time
we'll see each other as a committee
and beyond that we'll see each other in
reps Hall on June 8th
yes please
um the last question is just a
logistical question around the retained
bills and when we're going to discuss
how how we're I don't know if you have
names of people for all of them or how
we're working that so that we get them
on the schedule for the fall or start
talking about when that will happen
that's an excellent question I'm glad
you brought it up I'm actually going to
spend some time this week
looking at the retained bills and trying
to decide if there are any we can
discuss before the end of June and if
there are I will schedule one more
committee meeting
and I'll be discussing that with you
so we'll see what we can come up with
anything else
okay thanks everybody see you next time